listen some of you guys that are scared
I understand when I really read into Ana
so why is there a bit of a fear there
oh they're bigger okay and oh they could
say some stuff that could really hurt me
because of my past numbers I don't care
oh you know they have to have to have
manpower they're bigger than us
so what oh you don't understand but but
they know stuff that that if it comes
out and what if they find out about my
personal my business I'm like what if
they find I don't care
Titanic was built by professionals men
the ark was built by amateurs I like
being an amateur I like being naive I
like having a little bit of that with me
I like having a little bit of that with
my black eye and my scars and I'll you
know all these marks all over our body I
freaking like that I like the scar on
your face I like the scar in our belly I
like the scar in the back
I like those Mars I love those stitches
on our shoulders men it gets me
emotional I think about it my voice is
cranking right now man I think about
these stuff I know what we've done it
puts the fire on my belly like you have
no idea that's what gets me going and we
need some of you guys to really bring
that side of you out you haven't even
met that side of it once that fire got
in my belly guys there were not a lot of
things I was afraid of because I figured
out the formula I'm gonna work I'm gonna
improve and I'm gonna outlast you and
I'm going to think bigger than you when
I'm saying you you'd be in the
competitors once I figured that part out
and I realized that none of us are put
on this planet to the average and
ordinary and none of us are put here to
just go out there make millions live in
big houses nice cars travel the world
get the accolades and then we die no no
there's much bigger cause and
you
[Music]